في منطقه سويح الصحراويه القاحله جنوب
مدينه سليطن الواقعه شرق طرابلس يعمل
مزارعون منذ اكثر من ثلاثه اعوام لانشاء
اكبر مشروع هو الاول من نوعه في البلاد
لزراعه مليون شجره زيتون على مساحه 400
هكتار مع حلول عام 2027
حتى الان زرعت اكثر من
152000 شجره على مساحه 170 اكترا نحن هو
المشروع اولا مروي قطر بالتلقيط قطر زي ما
شفت المشروع ما يعتمد في يعني دايرين في
اسوا الاحوال ان ما فيش امطار زي الثلاث
سنوات هذه المشروع غريب التقطير اعتمدنا
على الاخبار الجوفيه العميقه مشاريع زراعه
الزيتون في ليبيا هي مشاريعه خاصه لا
تتدخل الدوله في انشائها ويامن اصحابها
هذا العام تعويضه خسارهم العام الماضي
يعول الليبيون على انتاج هذا العام من زيت
الزيتون لتعويض النقص الذي شهدته الاسواق
في الموسم الماضي اذا اشتكى المواطنون من
ارتفاع اسعار الزيت مقارنه بالسنوات
السابقه بعد وصول سعر اللتر الواحد الى
اكثر من خمسه دولارات في مناطق عده بسبب
ضعف الانتاج وشح الامطار مدينه غريان
الجبليه جنوب طرابلس تعاني نقصا شديدا في
المياه وتوجد فيها اكثر من مليون ومئتين
الف شجره زيتون اعتادت على المناخ الجاف
مما دفع المزارعين الى الري التكميلي احنا
التغيرات المناخيه مناسب هذا لها اثر
تاثير سلبي على اشجار الزيتون
وحاليا لاحظوا حتى فيها بعض صار فيها
النضج بفعل الحراره في غير وقتها تنتشر
معاصر الزيتون في غريان وعمومي غربي ليبيا
لكن نقص الانتاج هو من ثلاثه الاخيره عكس
سلبا على ادائها وعلى اسعار الزيت
فالمزارعون في هذه المناطق يبطلون الى جلب
المياه من مئات الامتار من ابار يكلف
حفرها اموالا باهظه
الزيتون وهذا ماثر على السوق يعني
ارتفاع سعر الزيت في حنيفه اكثر من 12
مليون شجره زيتون في ليبيا لكنها رهينه
لظروف المناخ فاعدادها تتراجع بسبب ارتفاع
درجات الحراره والجفاف الذي يفتك باشجار
الزيتون احمد خليفه الجزيره غيريان